hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today I'm
gonna explain a science fiction movie
from Fringe series seasons 4 called
forced perspective for your information
this is an anthology Series so the plot
has no correlation with the previous
episode
the movie begins with a teenage girl
named Emily malam who is drawing across
the street of Boston
she suddenly gets dizzy and immediately
draws a sketch of an unknown person in
her Sketchbook after she finishes the
drawing she chases after the man who is
walking across the street with his
co-worker and handsome the drawing they
walk past a construction site where a
steel beam falls from the crane and
impales him in the chest the woman opens
the sketch from Emily and is very
shocked as it somehow accurately
predicts the death of the man one of the
officers Lincoln calls detective Olivia
and informs her about the incident
she later orders him to collect all the
surveillance from the area to identify
the girl meanwhile Olivia returns home
and turns out that his father Jim malam
is aware of her gifted ability and has
been moving his family around the
country to keep the secret from the
public the next day Lincoln successfully
identifies the girl and tracks her move
but somehow still cannot figure out
where she lives back to Emily she is
riding on a bus when she suddenly gets a
vision again and sketches one of the
passengers but the man quickly gets off
the bus Emily tries to follow him hoping
that she can give the sketch to him as a
warning but the man disappears from her
sight after going door to door the
agents finally arrive at mallam's home
and show Jim Emily's picture but Jim and
the other family members lie to them
claiming that they don't know her
just after the agents leave the building
they coincidentally meet Emily on the
street and start asking questions
regarding his ability to predict
someone's death but the enraged father
runs out of the building and drags Emily
away from them Jim reveals that they
live as Nomads to avoid a corporation
called massive Dynamic that tries to
kidnap her daughter and study her
ability Olivia gives Jim her business
card offering to help them if the
corporation threatens them again
afterward Olivia confronts the executive
director of massive Dynamic named Nina
sharp and questions him about Emily she
admits that the company has put a huge
interest in her moments later the agent
receives a call from Emily who wants to
meet her face to face Olivia finds Emily
at a nearby Lakeside where the gifted
girl shows her the sketch that she Drew
on the bus earlier the sketch visualizes
a pile of dead bodies and building
debris around the bodies
Olivia brings the girl to a lab where
Emily reveals her ability she gets the
vision to be exact images of someone's
death in her mind when she sees a nearby
person who is about to die she continues
that she always tries to prevent the
incident from happening but the Visions
always come true
she is also afraid that the massacre is
going to happen the agents immediately
attempt to identify the man on the bus
who turns out to be Albert Duncan Olivia
also invites Jim to come over to the lab
to get a broader view about the incident
in the sketch Lincoln suggests Walter
hypnotize Emily allowing her to recall
the vision in her mind Emily is brought
back to the bus
she walks out of the bus and is
terrified when she encounters a lot of
people who are frozen in time trying to
run away from an explosion unfortunately
some of them are dead just as depicted
in the sketch as she walks through them
she finds a sign and informs everyone in
the lab
she also manages to spot Duncan's dead
body who is holding a Detonator one of
the guys recognizes the sign and informs
Olivia that the incident will take place
in the courthouse after that Jim and
Emily return home where the father spots
the same black van he saw in the
previous house and tells his daughter to
pack her bag realizing that Duncan is
going to blow up the courthouse bomb
squad is immediately deployed meanwhile
Duncan is present at the courthouse and
demands to meet judge O'Malley as
everyone is evacuated the bomb squad
discovers a set of bombs in the parking
lot however it will take too long for
them to disarm the bomb so Peter gets
the idea to block the specific radio
frequency which will prevent the
Detonator from working back to Duncan he
eventually meets the judge who ruled
against Duncan in a child custody case
and accuses him for ruining his life he
presses the Detonator but nothing
happens a few moments later the FBI
including Olivia arrives and surrounds
Duncan he reveals that he is backup
bombs wrapped in his body but Olivia
manages to calm him down and dunk and
eventually withdraws his intention to
blow himself up Duncan is then arrested
and everyone is safe
back at the house Emily disappears and
Jim thinks she has been kidnapped
however the agents confirm that the
black van is just a dry cleaning van
Olivia and Lincoln find the girl at the
lakeside where Emily sits in the cold
Olivia notices the sketch beside Emily
showing Emily with her dad sitting on
the same bench at the same time Jim
arrives and sits beside her daughter
with Olivia watching them just as
depicted the father Embraces Emily as
she dies from a stroke that resulted
from the overload of electrical activity
in her brain
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching